[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off the record where we talk
about whatever we want and we got Kelsey
back I love it when you come because
you're always complimenting us oh you
guys are great there's nothing bad to
say but first we have to talk about our
sponsor oh it's really cute okay we'll
talk about later yeah all right
nothing's cuter than Native got that
native create safe simple effective
products that people use in the bathroom
everyday native deodorant is formulated
without aluminum parabens and talc it's
filled with ingredients found in nature
such as coconut oil shea butter and
tapioca starch and it's never tested on
animals
that's awesome so making a switch to an
alum minim free deodorant does not mean
having to sacrifice our product
performance people love native they have
over 8,000 five-star reviews native
comes in a wide variety of scents for
men and women plus they release new
limited edition seasonal scents
throughout the year they also offer an
unscented formula and a baking soda free
formula for those with sensitivities
thank you they're classic deodorants
include coconut and vanilla lavender and
rosy you can burn mint and eucalyptus in
mint and there is no risk to try they
offer free return and exchanges in the
USA for 20% off your first purchase Wow
visit native dealer calm and use promo
code OTR during checkout this is my
personal one that I use right here and I
love the way it smells citrus and herbal
Musk you know what I like about it
though like it's not all like weird and
kinky and it smells like it smells fresh
yeah yes try it I want it yeah I love
citrusy smells and I also have cents
apiece yeah why don't you smell this
straight from the bar and this swatches
that's how you doing good Wow yeah
you're just watching Joe's armpit
no it's okay I use it here and I use it
in my other thigh pit behind the knees
or next to the balls
next to the balls hope that's a good
idea yeah it smells great though that's
how you know how powerful it is because
you don't smell anything else but the
delicious he order is so don't forget
for 20% off your first purchase visit
native deodorant calm and use promo code
OTR during checkout OTR baby on the run
I think the best part of it is aluminum
free it's not harmful ok we're moving
into sweater weather weather weather
your weather hey Canadians shut up but
like who else is seasonal depression
depression no one can talk today what
exactly seasonal depression so glad you
asked bye thank you
ah more time hits a nigga's sack no it's
the opposite it's when winter time has
yeah everyone
people get summertime depression do
we're gonna use it all summer time it's
like a dog shedding its fur a song for
every season and have a different coat
everyone gets fat no but it gets
brighter earlier so that's good so how
does the seasonal depression work it's
just it's literally called sad seasonal
ass depression no it's seasonal
affective when the season changes they
get depressed
yeah like what what is it what is it the
magnetic force that that pulls on your
heartstrings sure I like that metaphor a
lot of things are moving into the
holiday season which is happy the
cinnamon lots of snow cute ass family
[ __ ] you got lots of support you guys
are good-looking you gotta Instagram
famous kid yeah course the holidays are
a good time for you right see ya not
everyone kills that when people feel
very lonely during the holidays because
some people got beat every Christmas or
like people pass away and then they go
oh I wish they were here
I was in college I'm only child and my
parents are divorced so they're far away
from my school too and I really enjoyed
being alone at the time so you're
telling everyone else's like individuals
okay no I'm just like I don't know like
so right now everything is really cool
for me but then when it was the complete
opposite I thought was pretty cool too
yes the time of year where mood lamps go
up and sale like you know I got
Himalayan salt and presto Jack I know
you got the hell good about the lava
lamps so did I until she said mood
what's a mood lamp like it's like a lamp
that lights up it's made out of
Himalayan salt in salt releases positive
ions I got hit a Malayan salt back yeah
yeah it looks the [ __ ] out of mine
really
you sit there all day oh my mom gets
good deals on them oh yeah we have like
four of them at our house in fact real
Himalayan rock salt sweat yeah all you
[ __ ] that are getting on like their
trendy Himalayan rock salt like decorate
your apartment if it's not sweating on
your books it's not real so it's not
gonna help you
[ __ ] it melts it like just sweat yeah
it's kind of wet I don't know it's in a
different room maybe my mom has hookups
on a fake one I have a basket full of
Himalayan rocks and in the middle
there's a light bulb is that a mood lamp
kind of yeah okay it's like it's the
same concept yeah
there's I won that's a candle holder and
you could put it like a little tea light
in there mm-hmm
also diffusers like essential oil
diffusers very good for sad but that can
also that could [ __ ] your lungs up oh
yeah yeah I heard about that you have to
make sure it's really good great a
therapeutic grade and a certain sense
are safer for cats just like [ __ ] your
logs up do what I do I go into the spa
and I freakin do a eucalyptus bomb in
there
I get the oil and I just pour that [ __ ]
where the steam comes out and then
people alive why does it smell like
menthol and I'm like
I know you like a [ __ ] I'm in a public
place yeah you know can you do that
they're like complaining no they like it
you're like not you like it [ __ ]
have you ever smelled that at least ball
you know who did it wait oh my gosh I
had a very interesting encounter at that
place encounter with it a very tall
woman she was larger than myself
oh I'll be speaking about the same one
yeah I would have it it there's a lot of
reviews about this person I think oh my
god really
yeah I'm not alone no you're not alone
well it could take a dark turn get a
massage the season anyways yeah no I'm
already sad so let's just go there
massage and you're naked
and you're you know your bits are out
and she just put like a little tiny
towel over me and I was like that's
unique I usually am under like a sheet
or something maybe this is like the
culture and when I would get massaged I
just got credit carded oh that happened
to me too you're a lady or a stranger
walking no but I believe a stranger oh
wait did you do the bath scrub or did
you the Masaaki Imai Saji oh did you
enjoy the panel car let's cry if it was
by someone else I think maybe she had a
heads up she's like okay cool I signed
up for that got it
they're so aggressive - it's like you're
a piece of pizza dough those like
turnover yeah bucket of water on you I
was like I'm gonna stay - like I was
like oh she just happened a couple more
times I was like she wants an extra tip
yeah she she's kidding she's like making
sure to give you all of the places that
need to be massaged she's got a dirty
[ __ ] I don't know maybe she's trying to
help it out like we met [ __ ] I got the
massage service or the cleaning service
oh why didn't check maybe that was my
mistake get my oil change if you do the
cleaning service they scrub in if you're
dude they scrub your balls and they
scrub the apart between your balls in
their butthole - the taint the taint
yeah yeah only in Asia
I think they probably do it at we spa we
smile like when I get the scrub like
don't go hard on my nipples on my pretty
Rob though really close time I'm going
rough cuz and that shows me like I'm
just here to [ __ ] work I don't enjoy
it either it's all it's all light over
here might just avoid it all the way but
yeah I'd rather them just avoid it
they're gonna go that hard I'm like
through there's a dirty nipple chafing
guys what are you doing with your
nipples that they're so filthy
your nipples are bleeding they're like
you're welcome but that's not what we
were talking about so we were just
talking about what we saw on the reviews
we haven't encountered this person but
basically what's happening based on the
reviews because we were both very on
high alert I didn't even know that you
knew about it oh I told what cuz both
sides and right it's like oh yeah
there's a lot of reviews about that like
that's a regular person like a regular
customer that comes in often no there's
this there's this person who I guess
identifies as a woman um so she pays and
then she goes on the woman's side but
there's nothing to say that she's
actually a woman on the outside
physically so she has a beard I think
and all her male parts are still there's
no hormone they're fully intact
oh basketball player yeah just intruder
well no because she's saying that she
identifies as a woman and she has like
full wig on and like suede on but um
yeah yes but it's not they let they let
you why it's not like a like but it's
not like they're like doing their hair
like it's not like they did their like a
pickle with the wig it's like they took
a Halloween costume and just put it on
their head really quick like over their
hair that that's how that's what like
ruins everybody else's ability to like
identify what if I was a pervert well I
mean I am a pervert but what I would do
is I would put a wig on if I want to see
some tittays and pay for the female side
and walk in
this person's doing it it sounds like
happening the other thing is is like wow
Jill Jack off her dick it like in front
of kids and stuff sounds like it's more
intense than like this is a truth we're
cleaning very thoroughly though maybe
but it's yeah and they wanted to clean
out the old sperm that's benefit of the
doubt Jo you're really kind of
personable they need it to raise kids
there's like little girls and studs and
stuff in there yes mess it's really
interesting but then you the people
can't go to the front and complain
because then the front tires because the
front can't look can't be like oh we
like a trans exactly yeah but there if
there's a guy jacking off in the guy
section he'd get kicked out right yeah
they know it's jacking off or do they
not know the guy section for sucking
each other off and doing a l7 that
happens all the time
and then because one of the security
guards are fat and he was telling me all
this stuff and he was like yeah the
other day we had to call the police
because these two guys were in the
sleeping room sucking each other off
really hard I feel like that's a pretty
common ad the really hard part I added
that sexy about a steam room like we've
all watched that part right warm floors
you know it's like mysterious and Miss
Deane you can't see and it gets really
[ __ ] hot and you can barely breathe
and you're just like holy [ __ ] I'm
melting in here oh so there's a person
that identifies as a woman and but then
they're using that as a way to get in
and and have spank bank that's your
point zero zero one person exactly like
trans people if we you can even call
right it is because it's [ __ ] up how
do you turn this [ __ ] [ __ ]
from going in there and then that's what
gets a headline and then that's what
talked about and like we forget the
whole reason why that conversation even
brought up absolutely so many trans
women in there all the time bit like
they they're not a beautiful it's not
like it's not like that this guy this
girl is definitely not I don't know and
I'm saying something racist is that okay
okay I'm gonna say it anyway when
non-koreans and Asians
coming to weave all they [ __ ] it up
thank you very much when mainstream
Americans started coming because there's
no bathing culture and then it turned
into like a hook-up spot like it used to
be a family spot and there's all these
people just hooking up sucking each
other off left and right all day long
and it's like god damn dude and now
everyone wears [ __ ] shoes or sandals
inside no one's barefoot because
everyone's afraid of getting being warm
and [ __ ] like when you spray it on those
little chairs aren't you worried about
someone else's coochie that was just on
that chair at first you wash the chair
that's what you're supposed to that's
why it's a baby being culturally bathing
culture that's it's like like the
teenagers that ruin movie theaters they
go on then they start making out with
attorneys actually trying to watch movie
the bite finger banging each other I
don't mind making out the talking yeah
but I think it's the same thing more
like it's you actually talk the mom I
know that's what I'm going back I want
to [ __ ] talk to myself anyways keep
going Bart but I think that's I can ask
the same thing more like people that
don't understand the bathing culture and
and I think that's okay you can go in
there to learn but then there's also
people that are clear like one of the
things that I hate are there's all these
there's always Armenians that go in
there and they jump into the jacuzzi
fully clothed to show their dick yeah
and it's like you can see like like if
you don't know what Rome is doing when
in Rome just watch people right there's
like you can see all this guys doing
this okay cool maybe on my third try
I'll be just like everyone else but
there are people that refuse to
acclimate yeah there's people that like
you know those shorts that are on the
the people can use those mmm like those
shorts that they provide for you they
put those on and then they go and take a
shower with those shorts on yeah so
people are there scrubbing underneath it
yeah and in the still be soaked soaked
into the shorts and then they'll go
inside the water and then I'm like oh my
god dude and then I saw this old green
man like yell at the top of his lungs to
all these guys that were doing that yeah
and they were like oh my god this guy's
crazy I'm like man you [ __ ] up mm-hm
yeah that's I'm just rude people I don't
know it's like a PE uniform it's not
like meant to be maintained oh yeah and
it changed I just think the the the main
thing that I don't like about it is the
hook up stuff like everyone's just going
in like I don't mind if people are gay
and they're flirting or whatever but I
don't want them to [ __ ] when they're
there because there's kids there's
family there's whatever and then it's
like and me too like I'm just trying to
chill you seen it huh you seen it no no
no like my getting hit on and [ __ ] so
like I just want like I just want to
chill and relax just complaining he's
too hot females world
I just can't about getting hit on it's
my fault because I started flirting on
accident and I said hot nothing well you
exactly you were a smart phone Bert got
hit on to we're all hot we're all good
look good naked we can't have not hot
I'm just easy yes you have to make eye
contact like this when you oh did you
sigh deeply like no we were eating I was
eating and then I turned around and I
saw a guy staring and every time I catch
an eye with so much I just do one of
these because it's it's weird
no that is in gay culture that isn't
gonna suck your dick really fighting
about really I [ __ ] up no no I
should've though maybe I shouldn't have
been [ __ ] doing this when I said no
no I just did one of those and then he
came up to me and he's like oh is that
good and then I was eating like a stew
and I was like that's pretty good and we
started talking and in the sauna in the
food area naked part I'm talking about
the naked part yeah yeah yeah
and then we just talked and I don't date
she'll die makes
[Applause]
I make friends like it's never been done
no but then after that's what I realized
what was happening and then I was like
oh no I put myself in this seat at what
point when they ask you for his your
number when he asked you know no so that
so it was like multiple encounters with
the same person to where I found out oh
[ __ ] I'm getting like pursued mm-hmm
like this ain't just friends you know do
you have it that's what goes probably
feel like when they're friends on a guy
yeah you think oh this guy's my friend
yeah do you think men and women can be
friends no you don't anymore I used to I
used to be mostly friends with guys and
like I used to be like but we're friends
oh oh yeah that's true if they're in
relationships
the only time yeah or if it's like a
business relations friends it's like
yeah you know you're single thing yes to
single people you can know like it would
be weird if like you and Steve went to
dinner alone they'd be [ __ ] weird but
you're friends you know like that'd be
weird that we're friendly yeah what if
they're going to dinner to gossip about
people leave more and I was closer to
him I don't think it would be weird oh
it's like if you guys were closer than
us - I'm like okay if it was
non-business related I think it would be
kind of weird oh yeah yeah I mean that's
just a thing that's happened over time
acquaintances I would agree with you but
then for like a group or like a friend
group where were literally family I
wouldn't find that weird at all I mean I
would trust you both of them because
we're friends were all friends you know
like you mean why do friends no no yeah
but I mean I'm just a nice like me of
you you just haven't been on vacation
enough with this because we go on
vacation like I don't trust you it's
just like why does Steve want to go with
you and I'm just sitting at home like
this is probably more fun they knew that
day
or what if you're busy doing something
else like well go on vacation right and
like we all go hike somewhere yeah and
then we're such a big group and we're so
like tight sometimes we just play
musical chairs
let's see me and TIFF go off and we just
have like the 30 minute conversation
that's like there's no home to go to
like we're all the same place all we're
all experiencing new things we're all
like talking about this was like saying
she's saying like hey on Tuesday the 29
s that you want to go grab some like
food and drinks that's true cuz it's
like it's like you don't you don't call
Nikki and be like yo let's go grab some
dinner we don't have any be in combo he
doesn't eat but he doesn't do that to
Stevie you know it's the guns and Steve
was it yeah be with us shooting would
but that's different too so if you're
doing an activity so that's not a
definite date that's not I guess I don't
know I just
okay so that's the same [ __ ] we would we
would be doing it I would ask you I
think because that's how I make friends
male or female right like like all I'm
like girls to go hiking but I don't want
to [ __ ] them yeah you know like I want
to hike with them this is a good test to
my theory because I was in so in the
first relationship I was in I was like
we're all cool everyone could be friends
the second relationship I was in I was
like we're all cool we could all be
friends and he was kind of like going on
dates with girls like it's shitty any we
were living together and so then I was
like maybe it's not cool are you cool
with those girls no I didn't know that
we across the line I think but I think
if like your partner has a relationship
it's like we're all a group of friends
and then two people go off I think
that's different than like Steve's
friends with some girlfriend that's out
this might change your perspective like
if they were to if they were were to hit
you up I think you'd feel really
comfortable yeah that's fine I mean
right wait okay well you got JT's I'm
saying you guys have tested my theory so
I guess if it's a group and we're all
friends then it's okay for people to
splinter off and like oh we're just
friends but if it's like you met some
guy at a coffee shop and you're like
this is my new friend that's weird right
[ __ ] yeah that's exactly it so that's I
think those are the lines that must be
the line but listen that's an
acquaintance and you know what I'm
revising my theory there you go
peer pressure where the guy is gay what
what
[Music]
[Music]